next up coming in from luigy any
suggestions on how to better communicate
with people from other countries I mean
foreign languages different cultures
different beliefs so I mean Stevens a
great got to talk to is got offices
around the world you know thousands of
thousands of employees how do you handle
it Stephen yeah I think Luigi I think
the great thing is and this is the power
of the Internet is everything's
available and you can because I think
there's a love about business you want
to become always educated yourself more
and more i think you know Evan our vp a
great business people as it's great
people in life normally they're very
tolerant they love diversity they love
inclusion you know they've got a
tremendous outreach and you know
actually they kind of love the stranger
in May respect when you're going and
you're looking at your business with you
whether you're going come across the
border were you looking to going out to
asia or europe first one I honestly
again back to absence it is still a bit
of research about you know the culture
the difference and uneven likely in my
translate and then the other thing is
the great thing about if you live in
Canada you us you'll find loads of
people when they come from they it could
be you know Asia Africa and they're
probably within half a mile of where you
are can test drive some stuff in terms
of how I over to them and then I think
you know the great thing I've
experienced is obviously you know the
world is diverse and we celebrate the
tolerance and actually everything these
Muse fantastic about you know sensitive
I Toronto you walk down the street
they're fantastic multicultural center
same with New York same with London but
in reality what I would say the nice
thing about products and services if
you've got a great idea it can go global
it could go viral and and the Internet
has no respect for international
boundaries and that's the game changing
our 15 years and that gives you a huge
platform because you now have a cam
that is the world that is your canvas
that is your playground so I definitely
think it's worth I'm going for it
looking doing research on the web and
then you know grotech done its kind of
launcher if you were quickly in Italian
website and you know before you had to
get translated stuff you give you you
can you learn hoarder translation stuff
and then get an italian french esta
carta iris make sure it all makes sense
and you could go and have an e-commerce
platform de product and test driver into
that market place so it is just
incredible we've got loads to custom
this is a great custom rods Tim a prime
I understand the business up in the
North New England Yorkshire and he
started to create organic really healthy
food business and now I think she
exports to 29 countries are loaded it
from currencies and when she started her
journey she she was passionate about
healthy organic eat it and that was her
dream and really if we're honored to us
so she probably didn't know she'd be
successful as she happen and she didn't
know she'd be in as many countries but I
think what the power is and again it
comes back to kind of believe in
yourself and everything Evan talk to is
if you've got a great product almost if
you put it out there the market will
find it it will create a pool instead of
what was the old way where you have to
push push push push so that if you've
got that kind of cameras around the
world find out and do the research and
then I would go through a road test fit
test drive it and scare hell up put them
over water Emma yeah I have two sides
the first comes the first thing that
comes to mind is that the intent is most
important that I think a lot of people
avoid going into another market or deal
with different cultures because they're
just really worried that they don't
speak the languages they don't know the
culture and that prevents them from
taking any action your intent is most
important like if you know that you can
solve this person's problem in that
market then you should go out and do it
because it's coming from a good place
and yes you're going to make the
mistakes and you know you're going to
tip up a couple times and the thing that
gets you through is the intent like
you're not going in there trying to harm
the
you're going in there trying to help and
even if you make a couple mistakes you
say the wrong word that maybe you
mispronounced and it becomes something
offensive like you can work your way
through it because they can feel the
genuine care that you have to try to
help and don't let that fear of not
knowing the culture prevent you from
doing something potentially really
helpful and great in that market so
that's for a little about today I said
good you really take important you go
getta complain because I just gone
they're gone on just in the mood now so
go through it okay might the second
point was I think something that Stephen
does that you really well is he's all
he's always hyper aware what's happening
in the market to the places that he's
going to and so every time we get on you
talking about the Blue Jays he's talking
about my prime minister you know he's
always super wearing what's happening in
the market is going to I would like to
think that Stephens favorite baseball
team of all time years of Toronto Blue
Jays you're going to break my heart
Stephen it today good good but it's
really great at that and so if you know
you're going to a local market just
understanding some things about them
understand what's relevant in the news
understanding you know I like baseball
but I don't pay attention to other
things it allows you to have some points
of commonality and doing a little bit
more research and groundwork before
going in can really help just a couple
of touch points really how makes a
difference when you're communicating
with them hey you know what when you're
talking to us just listen and again you
got a great gift of putting a human
touch something just a little thing I do
when I go around the world is going to
Berlin next week I'm presented under
that a couple of thousand people but my
first three sentences will be in German
so you know you go if you're going to
meet or you got skype with people in
italy down in Brazil and you're looking
to strike some sort of partnership or
distribution agreement with them it's
pretty powerful especially actually face
to face it even learn a couple of you
know opening you just say you know
bonjour je m'appelle Steven Kelley and
you know I go to Canada up to Montreal
if I can speak a little bit in French
you know it means you break the ice
because I think what we forget and it's
so easy to forget because
the kind of vortices and I had tell us
people are you know strength 'as but the
reality is when you share a bit of
vulnerability like that and say look i
don't see very good french but at least
i had to go because I respect you and I
respect your nation and culture but and
I've always found people reach out and
actually embrace you and it's very
powerful it's just a very human thing to
say but it is something where you can go
to it if you're looking to go overseas
then as you say do a bit of research
about what topical what's happening news
what's happening with you know Justin
Trudeau and all that sort of stuff when
we go to Canada if the Blue Jays are
winning ah but then also just if you can
say a few words in their language it's
so powerful now I remember I used to go
to Tokyo out of business out there and
literally a first couple of sentences of
saying country and then that exhausted
my totality of my Japanese but honestly
you know you hear stuff about the
Japanese and they're very civilized and
they're very respect from a lovely
people but you hear it's really hard to
go to Japan it's a difficult market to
break into but I think if you share a
bit of interest in them and their
culture and if you can even say two
sentences then you find them grabbing
you and bringing you into their
community and making your success within
their world